nation that's the questions on my mind
why not you there's people who have
looked like you who have done it who are
less talented than you who have done it
who had less money than you who have
done it less resources less education
less support worse parents less
everything than you and they did it so
why can't you it's a question it's
always on my mind
everybody come in with their excuses
their reasons I can't do it because of
this and this and this and this and this
if there's somebody who has looked like
you who has done it why can't you
I look at Oprah and her story and this
woman sexually abused wasn't raised by
her parents was so poor that she had to
go to school on potato bags because her
grandmother who raised her couldn't
afford to buy her real dresses imagine
going to school in the potato bag can
you imagine that
like imagine your own childhood showing
up in school in a potato bag and to go
from that to where she is
most successful businesswoman in history
what's your Excuse
you got to get rid of the reasons you
get rid of the excuses you might look at
someone who's made it and had a head
start on you and you use that as the
reason why you're not successful what
there's plenty of people who came from
nothing we worse than you even the fact
that you you have a phone and you can
watch this live stream puts you ahead of
a huge chunk of the world puts you ahead
of a huge chunk of people who are going
to go on and crash it while you're
thinking about all the excuses that are
holding you back anyway it's on my mind
why can't you why can't you do it why
not you you have great ideas you're
talented you're a genius why not you
also if you want to know what I think
and what other successful entrepreneurs
think about building confidence check
out my new 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 250 four
days for free I will send you a 30
second to five minute video in the
morning
to help you build unstoppable confidence
the link is in the description below if
you want to be more confident you need
to surround yourself with things that
make you feel confident realizing that
any big endeavor is the collection of a
lot of small steps that came before if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through you're
more likely to do it because it doesn't
feel like work because you love doing it
[Music]
the most important if you have to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or that would be
like a little beacon if you want to see
me coach a young entrepreneur who hates
his job and is unsure what to do next
check out the video next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you are nothing
compared to what you could be so believe
it no but you're not taking the action